[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to some key MPEG now if you
know about Sonic dot exe this is the
spiritual successor to the game and
you'll see why
right about now ish haha did you see the
evil in his eyes right before you oh my
god copyrighted music
[Music]
okay anyway do I click on it Kabam what
do you got for me in Talia's tills tails
tamos who says spongebob the hills are
alive with the sounds of death so slow
oh I'm gonna have to replace all the
music in this game really I mean you're
not hearing the same music that I am but
it sounds familiar
maybe I can't believe it I have no idea
oh hey how's it going what is that oh
now all the dead animals are here oh no
oh my god I don't know if you're gonna
be listening your dad
was it good snus Neil please tell me it
was at least good snus knew before you
died you really don't know I mean some
key it's me
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's going on oh man I can't even pull
hi hi sung-ki what's going you're
looking good
you got to go fast you got this it's a
face worse life okay yeah this is
happening what's happened is it's dance
party oh boy I can't wait oh he's happy
I guess I knucks let's see what the hell
happens here cuz I don't know god I
don't know ahhh
spongebob you might not be able to run
but I may need to double check that oh
okay
what's with all the poopy clouds poopy
clouds don't look too happy about some
over on the right Captain Underpants I
never read that book when I was a kid
insert sonic quote that became on
outdated meme oh boy you mean
[Music]
oh no don't be overall what are you
doing knucks and don't the ladies will
be into enticed those clouds are running
away from here sometimes so many dances
to dance so little dance wouldn't you
dance I dance a dance the dance the
dance away come on Eggman what do you
got the sanctuary the sanctuary of what
hair hi mag man I'm gonna shut that
sonic by building another Sonic multiple
versions one metal one black
and it'll solve all many problems of
getting rid of the sonic waste getting
dark over here
I wonder what awaits me in I hope it
isn't a sonic audio apparently I'm
falling now damn it suddenly revealed
though
okay
go oh fashion ain't in the head smooth
okay that is it
Oh
I got the vapors hi how's it going some
key you're looking good
you wanna dance you fit the riddle what
does that mean what do they do yeah okay
we're done then I guess that's it thank
you everybody so much for watching
there's actually two more games made by
this guy I would love to play them but I
don't know how much of that was
copyrighted music I guess I'll just have
to find out so thank you everybody so
much for watching check out the
annotation for funny videos adapted in
the past and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
okay